our main story tonight is government
surveillance and I realize most people
would rather have a conversation about
literally any other topic including is
my smartphone giving me cancer to which
the answer is probably or do goldfish
suffer from depression to which the
answer is yes but very briefly but but
the fact is it is vital that we have a
discussion about this now because an
important date is just around the corner
one big data circle on the calendar when
it comes to a very controversial subject
the reauthorization of the Patriot Act
and all of the controversial provisions
there in June first they've got to come
to an agreement to reauthorize or
curtail this program yes some
controversial provisions within the
Patriot a Patriot Act are set to expire
on June the 1st so circle that date on
your calendars everyone and while you're
at it
Circle June 2nd as well because that's
Justin Long's birthday you all forgot
last year anything noticed now over the
last couple of years you've probably
heard a lot about strange sounding
programs such as xkeyscore muscular
prism and mystic which are
coincidentally also the names of summer
florida's least popular strip clubs
welcome to explore our dances are fully
unredacted and Tuesday is wing night but
but if you don't mind I would like to
refresh your memory over some of this
and let's start by focusing on the most
controversial portion of the Patriot Act
that is up for renewal section 215 which
I'm aware sounds like the name of an
Eastern European boy band
we are section 215 prepare to have your
hearts throb there's the cute one the
bad boy who want to strangle the potato
farmer and the one without an iron
deficiency they're incredible but the
contents of the real section 215 is
actually even more sinister
it's got section 215 nicknamed the
library records provision which allows
the government to require businesses to
hand over records of any quote
any tangible things including books
records papers documents and other items
if that sounds broad it's because it was
very much written that way section 215
so if the government can ask for any
tangible things so long so long as it's
for an investigation to protect against
international terrorism which is
basically a blank check it's not letting
a teenager borrow the car on the strict
condition that they only use it for car
related activities okay mom and dad I'm
going to use this for a in the
Wendy's parking lot but that is
correlated so I think um covers section
215 is overseen by a secret intelligence
court known as the FISA Court and
they've interpreted it to mean the
government could basically collect and
store phone records for every American
the vast majority of whom of course have
no connection to terrorism
unless aren't cheryl has been greatly
mischaracterizing the activities of her
needlepoint club it's a sleeper cell
isn't it aren't Sheryl you will hang for
this aren't Sheryl you're a traitor and
a terrible art not in that order
now the government will point out that
under 215 they hold phone records and
not the calls themselves what the
intelligence community is doing is
looking at phone numbers and durations
of calls they are not looking at
people's names and they're not looking
at content yes but that's not entirely
reassuring because you can extrapolate a
lot from that information if they knew
that you called your ex 12 times last
night between 1:00 and 4:00 a.m. for a
duration of 15 minutes each time that
can be fairly sure that you left some
pretty pathetic voicemails I don't care
who's monitoring this call Viki we
should be together pick up the phone
damn it I'm a human being not an animal
now the Patriot Act was written just
after 9/11 and for years it was extended
and reauthorized with barely a passing
thought in fact it became so routine
that when he was extended in 2011 one
newscast just tacked it onto the end of
a report about a presidential trip
abroad chip Reid CBS News traveling with
the president in Deauville France also
in France by the way President Obama
signed into law four-year extension of
the terrorism fighting Patriot Act also
in France by the way by the way he threw
that in like a mother telling her grown
daughter that her childhood pet just
died oh nice talking to you sweetie
also by the way mr. peppers is dead see
you at Christmas bang but all of that
was before the public was made aware of
what the government's capabilities
actually were because that all ended in
June of 2013 Edward Snowden is just
taken responsibility for one of the
biggest government leaks in US history
we learned that the government has the
capacity to track virtually every
American phone call and to scoop up
impossibly vast quantities of data
across the internet revelations that the
NSA eavesdropped on world leaders if
you've ever been to the Bahamas the NSA
could have recorded your phone calls and
stored them for up to a month yet all
that information was exposed by Edward
Snowden and it is still kind of
incredible that a 29 year old contractor
was able to steal top-secret documents
from an organization that literally has
the word security in its name clearly
that was not great for them because the
only place where it should be that easy
for employees in their 20s to steal is a
lid store dude you sure should take this
relax dude it's a Miami Marlins cap
we're not exactly selling Faberge eggs
here
it is still unclear exactly how many
documents Edward Snowden stole although
he has consistently tried to reassure
people that he put them in good hands
honestly I don't want to be the person
making decisions on what should be
public and what shouldn't
which is why rather than publishing
these on my own or putting now openly
I'm running through journalists now that
sounds great but of course it's not a
fail-safe plan as was proven when the
New York Times published this slide but
did such a sloppy job of blocking out
redacted information that some people
are able to read the information behind
that black bar which concerned how the
US was monitoring al-qaeda in Mosul a
group now known as Isis so essentially a
national security secret was leaked
because no one at the Times knows how to
use Microsoft Paint and look you can
think that Snowden did the wrong thing
or did it in the wrong way but the fact
is we have this information now and we
no longer get the luxury of pleading
ignorance it's like you can't go to Sea
World and pretend that Shamu is happy
anymore
when we now know at least half the water
in her tank is whale tears we know that
now you can't unknow that information so
you have to bear that in mind but here's
the thing it's now two years later and
it seems like we've kind of forgotten to
have a debate over the content of what
Snowden leaked a recent Pew report found
that nearly half of Americans say
they're not very concerned or not at all
concerned about government surveillance
which is fine if that's an informed
opinion but I'm not sure that it is
because we actually sent a camera crew
to Times Square to ask some random
passers-by who Edward Snowden was and
what he did and these are the responses
that we got I have no idea who Edward
Snowden is I have no idea I was loading
this I've heard the name I just can't
picture think right now exactly what it
is
Edward Snowden no I do not
just for the record that wasn't
cherry-picking that was entirely
reflective of everyone we spoke to
although to be fair some people did
remember his name they just couldn't
remember why he sold some information to
people he revealed some information that
shouldn't have been revealed I think
from what I remember is the information
that he shared was detrimental to our
military secrets and keeping our
soldiers in our country safe they can
leak documents but the US Army's
operations in Iraq Edward Snowden
revealed a bunch of Secrets I guess or
information into wiki wiki leaks that
were Snowden leaked he's in charge of
WikiLeaks Edward Snowden revealed a lot
of documents through WikiLeaks
Edward Snowden is not the WikiLeaks guy
the WikiLeaks guy is Julian Assange and
you do not want to be confused with him
partly because he was far less careful
than Snowden in what he released and how
and partly because he resembles a
sandwich bag full of biscuit dough
wearing a Stevie Nicks wig and that is
that is critical Julian Assange is not a
likable man even Benedict Cumberbatch
could not make him likable he's
uncomfortable that was supposed to be
physically impossible but but I don't
blame people for being confused we've
been looking at this story for the last
two weeks and it is hard to get your
head around not just because there are
so many complicated programs to keep
track of but also because there are no
easy answers here we all naturally want
perfect privacy and perfect safety but
those two things cannot coexist it's
like how you can't have a badass pet
Falcon and an adorable pet vole named
Herbert either you have to lose one of
them which obviously you don't want to
do or you have to accept some reasonable
restrictions on both of them now to be
fair the NSA will argue that just
because they can do something doesn't
mean they do do it and that there are
restrictions on their operations such as
the FISA Court which must approves
requests for foreign surveillance but in
34 years that Court has approved
over 35,000 applications and only
rejected 12 yes much like Robert Durst's
second wife the FISA Court is alarmingly
accepting listen Robert I'm not going to
ask you too many questions I'm just
going to give you the benefit of a doubt
that you clearly don't deserve at least
tell him to blink and burp less the
burping might be the most troubling
thing about that job so so maybe this
time for us to talk about where the
limits should be and the best place to
start would be section 215 not just
because it's the easiest to understand
but because there is widespread
agreement it needs to be reformed from
the President to Ted Cruz to both the
ACLU and the NRA to even the guy who
wrote the thing in the first place I was
the principal author of the Patriot Act
I can say that without qualification
Pyrus never did intend to allow ball
collections when it passed section 215
and no fair reading of the text would
allow for this program think about that
he was the author that's the legislative
equivalent of Lewis Carroll seeing the
teacups ride at Disneyland and saying
this has to be reined in no fair reading
of my text would allow for this right
you've turned my perfectly nice tail of
psychedelic pedophilia into a garish
vomitorium
this is not what I wanted and even the
NSA has said that the number of terror
plots in the u.s. that the section 215
telephone records programs has disrupted
is one and and it's worth noting that
one particular plot involved a cabdriver
in San Diego who gave eighty five
hundred dollars to a terror group and
that is the shittiest terrorist plot
I've ever seen other than the plot of a
good day to die hard but here's the big
problem here
if we let section 215 get renewed in its
current form without serious public
debate we're in trouble
because section 215 is the canary in the
coal mine if we cannot fix that we're
not going to fix any of them and the
public defect debate so far has been
absolutely pathetic a year ago a former
Congresswoman was discussing the 215
program on the news watch what happened
this vast collection of data is not that
useful and infringes substantially on
personal privacy I think at this point
we should seriously consider not gr not
continue congressman let me interrupt
you just for a moment we've got some
breaking news out of Miami
stand by if you will right now in Miami
Justin Bieber has been arrested
charges the judges reading the charges
including resisting arrest and driving
under the influence he's appearing now
before the judge for his bond hearing
let's watch actually you know what bad
news we're gonna have to interrupt your
interruption of the beeper news for a
new interruption this time featuring a
YouTube video of a tortoise having sex
with a plastic clog let's watch
that is essentially the current tone of
this vitally important debate and again
I'm not saying this is an easy
conversation but we have to have it I
know this is confusing and unfortunately
the most obvious person to talk to about
this is Edward Snowden but he currently
lives in Russia
meaning if you wanted to ask him about
any of these issues he'd have to fly all
the way there to do it and it is not a
pleasant flight and the reason I know
that is that last week I went to Russia
to speak to Edward Snowden and this is
what happened 48 paranoid hours in
Moscow arguably the last place on earth
where you can find an overweight Joseph
Stalin impersonator arguing with an
unconvincing fake Lenin and after
experiencing Russia's famously warm
hospitality I went to meet Edward
Snowden who was supposed to show up in
this room at noon however at five
minutes after the interview was
scheduled to begin
I had a troubling thought I don't know
these coming because my argument is why
would II when you think about it I got
2,000 rubles that says he doesn't make
it without understanding how much that
is all I'm saying is a 10-hour flight
for an empty chair I'm gonna lose my
okay turns out there might be a bit of a
problem because a whole Russian producer
booked us in a room directly overlooking
the old KGB building and the home of the
current Federal Security Bureau and
we've just been told they know we're
here
so um so that happened just if if the
Russian Russian KGB is listening ring
the fire alarm if he's not coming
the most famous hero and/or traitor in
recent American history and I've started
with a question designed to test his
loyalties how much do you miss America
you know my country is something that
travels with me you know it's not just a
geography already a way too complicated
answer the answer is I misses a loss the
greatest country in the world I do
that's my country I do miss my home I do
miss my family
do you miss Hot Pockets yes I miss
highpockets very much okay um the entire
state of Florida let's just let that
silence hang in the air
shut nuts do you miss Prague nuts I
don't know what they are lucky for you
it would
not just truck nuts stars-and-stripes
truck nuts that is two balls of Liberty
in a freedom sack
you really thought ahead well at least
one of us did no because of the UM the
quandary the CAF guess nightmare that
you you're in okay
let's dive in why did you do this the
NSA has the greatest surveillance
capabilities that we've ever seen in
history now what they will argue is that
they don't use this for nefarious
purposes against American citizens in
some ways that's true but the real
problem is that they're using these
capabilities to make us vulnerable to
them and then saying wow I have a gun
pointed at your head I'm not gonna pull
the trigger
trust me so what's the NSA you want look
like because you applied for a job at
the NSA where you clearly see an
inherent value in that shadowy
organization I worked with mass
surveillance systems against Chinese
hackers I saw that you know these things
do have some purpose and you want your
spies to be good at spying to be fair
right what you don't want is you don't
want them spying inside their own
country
spies are great when they're on our side
but we can never forget that they're
incredibly powerful and incredibly
dangerous and if they're off the leash
they can end up coming after us
but just because we want two different
things here domestic surveillance and
fallen surveillance because domestic
surveillance Americans give some of a
about phone surveillance they don't
give any remote about well the
second question is when we talk about
foreign surveillance are we applying it
in ways that are beneficial no one cares
in terms of no because I don't give a
we spied on UNICEF The Children's
Fund sure we spied on lawyers
negotiating I was UNICEF doing
I mean that's the question there isn't
it the question is are these programs
valuable are we going to be safer when
we're spying on UNICEF and lawyers who
are talking about the price of shrimp
and clove cigarettes I don't think
people say that's good I think they'll
say I definitely don't care
Americans do not give a I think
you're right about foreign survivors
what some people do care about is
whether Snowden considered the adverse
consequences of leaking so much
information at once how many of those
documents have you actually read I've
evaluated all the documents during the
archive you've read every single one
well I do understand what I turned over
but there's a difference between
understanding what's in the documents
and reading what's in the documents I
recognize the concern what giving you
because when when you're handing over
thousands of NSA documents the last
thing you want to do is read them I
think it's fair to be concerned about
did this person do enough were they
careful enough were they handling
material like we know you're handling
well in my defense I'm not handling
anything anymore that's been passed in
the journalists and they're using
extraordinary security measures to make
sure that this is reported in the most
responsible way but those are
journalists with a lower technical skill
set than you that's true but they do
understand just like you and I do just
how important it is to get this right so
so the New York Times took a slide
didn't redact it properly and in the end
it was possible for people to see that
something was being used in Mosul on al
Qaeda that is a problem well that's a
cop it is a cup and these things do
happen in reporting in journalism we
have to accept that some mistakes will
be made
this is an a fundamental concept of
Liberty right but you have to own that
then you're giving documents with
information you know could be harmful
which could get out there yes
if people act in bad faith he's not even
talking about bad fight it's gonna
incompetence we are but you will never
be completely free from risk if you're
free the only time you can be free from
risk is when you're in prison while the
risks were significant Snowden himself
has made it clear he feels the rewards
have been worth it you said in your
letters of Brazil I was motivated by a
belief that the citizens of the world
deserve to understand the system in
which they live my greatest fear was
that no one would listen to my warning
never have I been so glad to have been
so wrong how did that feel I was
initially terrified that this was gonna
be a 3-day story everybody was gonna
forget about it but when I saw that
everybody around the world said whoa
this is a problem we have to do
something about this it felt like
vindication even in America even in
America and I think we're seeing
something amazing which is if you ask
the American people that make tough
decisions to confront tough issues to
think about hard problems if they'll
actually surprise you okay here's the
problem I did ask him Americans and boy
did it surprise me I have no idea who
Edward Snowden is no I have no idea who
I was loading this I've heard the name I
just can't picture think right now
exactly what it is well
he sold some information to people he
revealed some information that shouldn't
have been revealed Edward Snowden
revealed a lot of documents through
WikiLeaks Edward Snowden revealed a
bunch of secrets I guess or information
into wiki wiki leaks I worse know been
leaked he's in charge of WikiLeaks I'm
in charge of WikiLeaks know I deal I
guess on the plus side he might be able
to go home cuz it seems like no one
knows who the you are everybody family
informed so did you do this to solve a
problem I did this to give the American
people a chance to decide for themselves
the kind of government they want to have
that is a conversation that I think the
American people deserve to decide oh
there's no doubt it is a critical
conversation but is it a conversation
that we have the capacity to have
because it's so complicated
we don't fundamentally understand it it
is a challenging conversation I mean
it's difficult for most people to even
conceptualize the problem is the
Internet is massively complex and so
much of it is invisible service
providers technicians engineers the
phone okay let me stop you right there
because this is the whole problem right
this is the whole problem I just I
glazed over because it's like the IT guy
comes into your office and you go oh
don't teach me anything I don't want to
learn you smell like canned soup it's
another challenge to figure out how do
we communicate things that require sort
of years and years of technical
understanding and compress that into
seconds of speech so I'm sympathetic to
the problem there but the thing is
everything you did only matters if we
have this conversation properly so let
me help you out there you mentioned in
an interview that the NSA was passing
around naked photos of people yeah this
is something where it's it's
actually seen as a big deal in the
culture of NSA because you see naked
pictures all of the time
that's terrifies people because when we
ask people about that this is the
response you get the government should
not be able to look at dick pictures if
the government was looking at a picture
of Gordon's penis I definitely feel it
would be an invasion of my privacy yes
the government was looking at pictures
of my penis that would upset me they
should never ever the US government have
a picture of my dick it's my husband
sent me a picture of his penis and the
government could access it I would want
that program to be shut down i would
want the dick-pic program change
I would also want the dick-pic program I
think will be terrific if the program
could change I would want it to be
tweaked I would want it to have have
clear and transparent laws that we knew
about and that were communicated to us
to understand what they were being used
for or why they were being kept do you
think that program exists I don't I
don't think that program exists at all
no no no no if I had knowledge that the
US government had a picture of my dick I
would be very pissed off well the good
news is there's no program named the
dick-pic program the bad news is they're
still collecting everybody's information
including your dick pics what's the
over-under on that last guy having sent
a dick pic recently you don't need to
guess I'll show you I did take a picture
of my
and that's it little girl recently but
this is the most visible line in the
sand for people can't they see my dick
so with that in mind look inside that
fault that is a picture of my dick so
let's go through each NSA program and
explain to me its capabilities in
regards to that photograph of my penis
so 702 surveillance can they see my dick
yes the FISA Amendments Act of 2008
which section 72 falls under allows the
bulk collection of Internet
communications that are one end foreign
bulk collection now we're talking about
my dick so if you have your email
somewhere like Gmail hosted on server
overseas or transferred overseas err at
any time
crosses outside the borders of the
United States your junk ends up in the
database so it doesn't it doesn't have
to be sending your dick to a gentleman
ah no even if you sent it somebody
within the United States
you're wholly domestic communication
between you and your wife can go from
New York to London and back and get
caught up in the database executive
order twelve triple three dick oh no
dick yes
yo twelve triple three is what the NSA
uses when the other authorities aren't
aggressive enough or they're not
catching as much as they'd like for
example because how are they gonna see
my dick I'm only concerned about my
penis when you send your junk through
Gmail for example yeah
that's stored on Google's servers Google
moves data from data center to data
center invisibly to you without your
knowledge your data could be moved
outside the borders of the United States
when your junk was passed by Gmail the
NSA caught a copy of that prism prism is
how they pulled your junk out of Google
with Google's involvement all of the
different prism partners people like
Yahoo Facebook Google the government
deputizes them to be sort of their
little surveillance Sheriff there are
dick Sheriff correct upstream upstream
is how they snatch your junk as it
transits the Internet
okay mystic if you're describing your
junk on the phone yes but do they have
the content of that junk call or just
the duration of it they have the content
as well but only for a few countries if
you are on vacation in the Bahamas yes
finally and you need to remind yourself
I'm just not sure what to do with this
it's just a lotta just hold onto it it's
a lot of responsibility yeah it is a lot
responsibility that's the whole point
should I know you should absolutely not
and it's unbelievable that you would do
that actually it's entirely believable
to fifteen metadata know what come on
and they can probably tell who you're
sharing your junk pictures with because
they're seeing who you're texting with
who you're calling if you called a penis
enlargement center 3:00 in the morning
and that Cole lasted 90 minutes
they would have a record of your phone
number calling that phone number which
is a penis enlargement center they would
say they don't know it's a penis
enlargement center but of course they
can look it up I would if the American
people understood this they would be
absolutely horrified I guess I never
thought about putting it in the
at the context of your junk food a good
takeaway from this be until such time as
we've sorted all of this out just don't
take pictures of your dick just don't do
it anymore no if we do that if we wait
hold on what you're saying no you should
keep taking busy to be big yes you
shouldn't change your behavior because a
government agency somewhere is doing the
wrong thing if we sacrifice our values
because we were afraid we don't care
about those values very much that is a
pretty inspiring answer to the question
hey why do you just send me a picture of
your dick because I love America that's
why so there you have it America all of
us should now be equipped to have this
vital debate because by June 1st it is
imperative we have a rational adult
conversation about whether our safety is
worth living in a country of barely
regulated government sanctioned dick
Sheriff's
and with my work here done there was
just time to take care of one more thing
finally congratulations on citizen for
winning the Oscar I know you couldn't be
at the ceremony for obvious reasons so
huh Wow I thought we celebrate ourselves
Cheers wow that's really do this up and
thank you Oh welcome what's the
over-under on me getting back home
safely well if you weren't on the list
before you are now like um is that like
a lazy eye look at Joe College is that
actually possible no it's it's it's a
real thing you're associated now okay
just to be clear NSA I never met this
guy so take me off your king list
because I do not want to get stuck in
Russia
you know
we we got in touch with the NSA the
National Security Council and the White
House and we asked them to comment on
the dick-pic capabilities of each of the
program's Edward Snowden just discussed
which incidentally were some very fun
emails to write to government agencies
they did not wish to comment on the
record and I can see why for every
possible reason
you